well maybe some of your kids have found
their passion for art while
homeschooling
well you're in luck rocky thea stopped
by the new park west gallery at caesar's
palace to show us
how your family can be inspired by the
pros
yeah we could all use a little
inspiration during this time and i think
park west gallery has
plenty especially plenty of inspiration
around here that's for sure
especially on this side of the gallery
with your work here behind us
tim yankee tell us about your work and
just and what your what your inspiration
is
sure well you can see i have a couple of
themes here where pure abstract
uh the national flag with uh honoring
the veterans
uh vietnam veterans to even abstracts as
well so
and this is uh an accumulation of years
and years of heading out west when i
first
was 13 years old i came out west for the
first time in this area
and arizona as well and i was just drawn
to it the colors
of the native americans like you can see
here just i was just drawn to
the vibrancy and being a color artist
like some of the other artists around
here it's just i really
attached myself to that and made a
career out of painting color
from abstract dream life it is the dream
life i'm very fortunate
that's wonderful and i was telling you
earlier you know when i when i paint it
just kind of accidentally becomes
abstract but don't forget to sign it
there's a technique to it all right
there you go
and um i i feel like when people come in
here they have to be open-minded
and just ready for to accept what
they're what they're looking what kind
of mindsets that's exactly right
they should come in here with the
mindset of
not reading these paintings like a
paragraph but listening to them
with your eyes you know listen to them
like a song you know just submit
yourself to them
and not to over analyze it too much i
love that just accept it for what it is
beautiful beautiful words from the pro
here